hello thank you for joining us today for
the third and final webinar in our data
science series curating data and
integrating the Wolfram data framework
I'm very pleased to welcome today's
presenters Alan Joyce director of
content development with Wolfram Alpha
and Aaron and right data scientist with
Wolfram Alpha Alan we'll begin today's
webinar with his presentation on how to
augment your work with the Wolfram
knowledge base Aaron will follow with
his talk creating a data resource where
he'll import data from the American
presidency project online data archive
and show us how to clean structure and
visualize the extracted data we'll also
be sharing some online resources and
links with you along the way to guide
you as you become more familiar with the
Wolfram data framework and Alan and
Aaron will take time to respond to your
questions at the end of the webinar my
name is Jaime Peterson technical
programs manager with Wolfram research
and I'm your online host for this data
science webinar series I'm joined by
several of my Wolfram colleagues behind
the scenes to respond to your type
questions during the webinar and help
point you to the resources you need
today's webinar is an opportunity for
you to get started using the Wolfram
language for algorithmic knowledge and
extracting data with the Wolfram data
framework the presentation notebooks
will be available to you to download
during the webinar and before passing
the microphone to Alan I'm going to ask
a quick poll question it's going to ask
wolfram technologies you've used when
the poll question appears on your screen
please select your responses and we'll
share the answers after everyone has a
chance to respond as you can see looks
like a good majority 78% have used
mathematic and the Wolfram language and
we're grateful for that
but about half if you've also been
working with Wolfram Alpha and 30% the
Wolfram cloud but well from data
repository will be something we'll talk
more about today so you will learn more
about that so thank you for giving us
those results and Alan I think I found
those interesting I'm ready to turn
things over to you following that bowl
great thanks very much Jamie hopefully
you can see my screen now so I'm Alan
Joyce I'm the director of content
development for Wolfram Alpha and today
I'll be sharing a little bit of history
and an overview of some of the key
features of the Wolfram data framework
as well as some tips and examples of how
you can effectively use this framework
to improve and extend external data
sources you may be working with with
your own projects so what is the Wolfram
data framework at its core it's a
collection of Wolfram language symbols
that represent real world objects
concepts and data the data structures
that contain and organize the data
represented by those objects and
functions that can operate on analyze
visualize that data at the core of all
this is the Wolfram knowledge base which
contains millions of canonical entities
from hundreds of different domains
representing all different kinds of
objects people countries chemicals those
elements
books movies anatomical structures even
Pokemon and each of those entities can
have dozens or even hundreds of distinct
properties whose values are encoded in
flexible powerful Wolfram language
representations of things like
quantities and units dates and times
geodetic datum graphs and more so the
developments of this framework has been
proceeding steadily for more than decade
now you know from the the launch of the
first built-in data packets in
Mathematica in 2007 through the launch
of Wolfram Alpha which is itself mostly
a giant Wolfram language program and
then the subsequent integration of that
Wolfram Alpha knowledge base back into
the language and then the introduction
in the language of more features like
data objects time series and more and
most recently the launch of the Wolfram
data repository just last year so
longtime users of the Wolfram language
seems like we've got a fair number of
them today will most likely have some
familiarity with the earliest data
packets country data element data
chemical data you know these were all
domain-specific functions that give
direct access to data on entities of
different types you know quantities
units numbers time series 3d graphics
models of molecules all sorts of useful
in a relatively small number of domains
though you know after that then we
introduced Wolfram Alpha and and this
started from the backbone of those very
early data packets but added hundreds of
other domains as well as a simple you
know non programming interface we
Wolfram Alpha was designed to allow
users to access all that data retrieve
it perform sophisticated computations
with data from all those domains using
just natural language queries what
Wolfram Alpha didn't do at least at the
time was let you delve deeper into the
data and extract raw data use it in your
own projects so the next step was really
integration a very early integration of
Wolfram Alpha itself into the Wolfram
language so the Wolfram Alpha function
essentially gives you a view of Wolfram
Alpha results inside a notebook and
Wolfram Alpha and any input will return
the results in a list of pods you know
it's it also allows for the extraction
of other kinds of data from those pods
so you might want to get computable data
time series data let me just refresh
here a moment but what this allows other
people and we've seen people use a lot
of really interesting things here it
lets you pull some of that data from
Wolfram Alpha and use it directly like
you would any other data packet data
things from country data element data
anything else and this is really useful
you know I but still Wolfram Alpha was
essentially designed as a one-shot
experience you know you've got a single
question and an answer to that there
there isn't really a good way to do lots
of programmatic diving into these
domains so where this really became a
framework that's of real use to Wolfram
language users was with the full
exposure of entity value and the entity
framework so this framework really is
essentially the same framework used
internally by Wolfram Alpha to represent
and compute answers to questions that
come through the Alpha website or our
API you know control equals open
a natural language input field that can
interpret entities on their own it can
interpret entities and their properties
and you know retrieve the the values for
those entity property combinations they
can be more complex queries like you can
type in give me the five largest
countries by population and that gives
you an implicit entity class that you
can then list out the members of that
class and get access to those entities
and then any of the other data you want
to retrieve for those and you know this
is this is kind of the way that we view
data inside of alpha and now this is
exposed in the Wolfram language and so
people have access to all the sorts of
birthplaces dates
quantities everything that you might
want to know about people and countries
and places and platypuses there's a
platypi but so this is this has been the
culmination of a long process of
learning how to work with data in the
Wolfram language expanding on those
datasets in Wolfram Alpha and then
bringing all that knowledge back to the
Wolfram language so that you know users
can make use of what's in the knowledge
base can make use of all these
structures and work a lot better with
data of their own and enhance it with
stuff that's in the knowledge base I'll
touch briefly here on the Wolfram data
repository which is the most recent
edition here you know because the task
of growing the Alpha knowledge base is
essentially never-ending there's more
data being added all the time in every
possible domain and there's a world of
data out there that may be too niche or
specialized to be of general interest to
Wolfram Alpha users it's going to be a
long time before we get to all of those
sorts of datasets but the data
repository is a chance to have you know
it's a public repository there are some
wolfram curated datasets in there
Wolfram language users can submit
datasets to it and share them with other
people the resources are searchable
directly within the language and
immediately accessible and this is
really the key point and what's relevant
to our talk today is these are data sets
that have gone through a process of
curation and enhancement and applying
Wolfram data framework
structures and entities to these raw
data set so that they're instantly
useful in the Wolfram language you can
you can make use of all the sorts of
advanced visualization time series
operations retrieving additional data on
canonical entities without having to go
through the process of cleaning those up
yourself and you know this is the kind
of thing where the the raw data set here
is just a big CSV now this is a nicely
form data set that has quantities it has
data objects it has coordinates you can
immediately generate maps with a single
line of code and do all sorts of
advanced operations on it I mean I
mention this here Stephan introduced
this data curation hierarchy when we
launched the data repository so it's a
useful way of thinking about the overall
process of bringing data into the
language and the different levels of
clean-up and curation and enhancement
you can apply to them I think for today
between Aaron and I were touching mostly
on steps four through seven you know
step zero through the third step are
mostly different levels of quality and
structure that have been applied to raw
data sets once we get in here we're
talking about normalizing things to
quantities dates locations entities
creating custom entity stores doing some
analysis of that data so this is sort of
the zone that we're focused on today so
a relatively simple example here I'm I'm
starting with some sample data from the
US Department of Health and Human
Services and this is a data set of Head
Start Center locations for people who
work with the Wolfram language you know
you know that just getting in something
that's a nice clean CSV is as simple as
import the file location or the web
address here once you've got that though
this is a little hard to make sense of
some in some ways it's it's pretty clean
it's a simple data set you've got a
header row you've got some data you can
see their coordinates you can see there
are states and cities there are things
we might align here but if you want to
work with this
you know I find that it's a little bit
easy to start putting things into
associations so I'll here I'm building a
list of associations by threading the
header row across all the rest of the
rows in this data set and I end up with
a bunch of records that are like this so
every field has a name and that means
you can go in and you can start just
picking out specific columns out of that
data set if I just want to get the name
city and state for all these things
that's a trivial thing to do personally
and for the purposes of the data
repository and and as people are sharing
datasets
I find that it's nice to go a step
further and actually put things into a
Wolfram language data set this preserves
most of the functional features of
associations but you get a nice
interactive interface you can page
through data you can dig down into
individual columns if you want - I'm
looking values but it's it's a nice way
of starting to work with you know larger
structured data sets and the same thing
here you can you can start selecting out
bits of that data set you can say I just
want to get all the rows that are early
head start centers in Rhode Island and
it's it's a matter of a one line of code
to pull all that stuff out so we've got
this in an in a nice Wolfram language
structured form at that point we want to
start about looking at normalizing some
of these values we want to apply some of
the really useful features of the
Wolfram data framework to this data set
so we could see that before there were
coordinates there's a latitude column
and a longitude column yeah this is one
of the easiest things to clean up a
normalize here so we can start with that
and here I'm just you know you could go
through and start replacing the existing
content I'm just prepending a column so
you can see how things look in the raw
data set compared with what I'm adding
here so I'm prepending a column that I'm
just gonna call position and I'm
grabbing the latitude and longitude
values wrapping those in geo position
and mapping that over the whole data set
and I end up with column for each Center
that has a Geo position for each of
those
locations and so once you've got that
then you know immediately geo histograms
list plots you know all the sorts of
geographic visualization that you can do
in the language you can do very easily
you can start to get a sense of you know
where is the greatest density of some of
these locations that maybe
unsurprisingly its major population
centers but still it's an easy thing to
do and you could dig down into specific
States you know other locations and look
at how how these centers are distributed
there this data set doesn't really have
any fields with quantitative values and
things that have units but the same kind
of process applies we could take that
earlier example I was showing from the
data repository of a meteorite data set
and this is just a NASA data set if the
JSON file we can import this make it
into an association and wrap that in
data set and we've got this is the raw
data so we can see again here there are
there are coordinates that we would want
to clean up there's also a mass value
and we can find out from looking biggest
source that that mass column is values
in grams so you know you can start
thinking well we'd be really useful to
have those not just as numbers where if
I share this data set with someone I
have to say okay well masses and grams
you know the years of dates another
column is and is in meters
but we turn these things into language
quantities so the trivial thing at least
as it would seem is you know again let's
let's add a column here and let's call
it mass quantity and I'm just going to
take all the the mass values and I'm
going to wrap them in quantity and say
those are grams and map that over all
the rows that have a mask great I've got
a grams unfortunately you might say okay
now I want to start visualizing those
things the bar chart fails because it
turns out the original import those
values were strings and all we did was
say take that value stick it in quantity
quantity doesn't know that one string is
supposed to be larger than the other so
you need to think a little bit about
what state the raw data is and you could
have gotten around that by converting
those values to integers or reals at
that stage but what is even more useful
in many cases is learning how to use
interpreter and the Wolfram language and
interpreter there are as many
interpreters actually more as there are
different types of entities in the
Wolfram language so there's an
interpreter for buildings for countries
there are also other kinds of computed
and structured interpreters for
quantities dates and times you know all
sorts of different entities and other
types of structures so in this case we
could say again let's just take all the
rows that have a amassed value and we
are going to interpret each of those
masked values as being a quantity with
the unit grams and so what we get out
there again looks like the same looks
like the same column but this actually
does what we wanted to so we can we can
start visualizing things we can generate
plots of those values we can start
sorting and extracting data you know
here I'm taking the the top I have
meteorites by mass and grabbing the
names and masses and if you like me and
you still haven't quite gotten
completely internalized the metric
system and it's hard to think about what
23 million grams is having things as
quantities means you can just instantly
convert those to any other compatible
unit that you might want to so one of
the things that's really really powerful
and flexible about having things
represented as canonical data types
quantities dates and so on so
coordinates quantities the unit these
are immediately useful you can compute
with them right away there they have all
sorts of additional features that lets
you use all sorts of other functions in
the language but when you have columns
in a data set where some of those values
can be aligned to you know any of the
canonical entities in the Wolfram
language that opens up a whole other
world of computer
that means that you align some data
value like Alabama or gold or Mount
Everest to the canonical representation
of that thing in the language and then
you can access any of the curated data
values that we have for those specific
entities you know data values that may
not be in some related data set that
you're working with but can be used to
enhance that data set so since this data
set has a column with US state
abbreviations that's pretty easy to
align and here we're just going to say
there is a US state interpreter and I'm
going to apply that to the state column
in this data set which has state
abbreviations and just add a column for
that and so we end up with States you
know this is this is an alignment that
generally I'm going to be pretty
confident in as long as we believe that
all the all the abbreviations in that
column are state abbreviations we're
going to get them right the first time
there's no there's no redundancy and
those those abbreviations so if you
believe all all of them to be US states
that's what you're going to get out here
so you might be feeling really proud of
yourself and say well I'll go do this
I'll do the same thing Citi Field but
when you do that where you're just
saying I want to interpret whatever's in
this city column as a city the city
column only has its city name it doesn't
have any other context to it it doesn't
say that it's for example Alton Missouri
so interpreter works basically like
Wolfram Alpha you know you you feed in a
string and we try to interpret it as a
particular thing by default that may not
be the specific thing that's referred to
in your data set you know for whatever
reason this may be because you know I'm
currently in Illinois so it thinks that
I'm most interested in the Alton that's
closest to me this is the the Alton
Illinois the Alton City that I get out
for things like Brooklyn Ohio and this
was Brooklyn New York which there is an
extra complication when Brooklyn New
York is not really a city it's it's a
borough it's a county and so it's an
administrator Division type entity in
the welcome language so there's a few
tweaks that we need to make here but
you can work around this again pretty
easily by saying I'm gonna take this
time I'm gonna join together the sitting
in state columns so instead of just
album I'm gonna have album Missouri and
I'm going to interpret that string as a
city or the administrative division and
I'm going to add that again as the city
column here and so what we get out here
you know the state's match up things
look pretty good this seems like a
pretty plausibly good alignment between
all of these cities and states there's a
lot of power here but they're there also
because there is so much data and
because there can be ambiguity when
you're trying to interpret any
particular string the more context you
can feed to interpreter often the better
your results you're going to be so it's
just something to watch for when you're
doing this so I'm gonna I'm gonna shift
here and instead of continuing with the
raw data set I'm working with there is
an expanded version of this data set in
the Wolfram data repository already that
already has cities and states and zip
codes and other things aligned to their
canonical representation in the language
so just to switch this and as a
demonstration in this data set we have
for example zip code entity alignment
for each of these centers so because we
have that we could also start inserting
data from the Wolfram knowledge base
into this external data set so for this
example we're saying let's take the zip
code entity associated with each Center
and I'm going to add a column with the
population under five for that zip code
and the median income and this is just
taking that entity and accessing the
property population with a qualifier
where age goes to an interval of you
know quantity 0 to 5 years and household
income again just taking that entity and
accessing property for median household
income and mapping that over a well here
just a sample of rows and what you get
out is some really potentially useful
data for the zip code associated with
each one of these centers
so then we can start putting all this
together no here's let's do this for for
a specific subset here I'm going to take
all of the head start locations that are
in the city of Pittsburgh I'm going to
do the same operation I'm gonna prepend
columns with population under five and
median income for each of those if codes
and then I can generate a Geo region
value plot a basically a choropleth map
heat map for each of those properties
and then just a list plot of all of the
centers that were pulled out in this
this subset of the data and then with
that you can start taking a closer look
at you know you can look where the where
the distribution of centers is and how
that matches up with different regions
the first year we have a population
under five by zip code so your darker
areas are larger populations down here
median household income darker areas our
higher household income and you this is
this is the start of some analysis of
you know where these centers are located
in relation to centers of relevant
population and in relation to you know
where most of the household income is
concentrated in this area so you can see
you know the having that alignment is
not just a not just a convenience I mean
it's it it is something that lets you
tap into a much much larger data set of
curious of curated knowledge that you
can add to your own data sets the last
thing I'm going to touch on here so I
leave plenty of time for Aaron and for
questions is custom entities an entity
store I mean obviously the there are
there are many more entities in the
known universe than then we have got in
Wolfram Alpha right now or in the wolf
knowledge base and so entity store is a
very powerful tool and this is again
coming right out of how we describe and
define data types in Wolfram Alpha
and this lets you define your own entity
types which can be used just like any of
the built-in type the language can be
you know deployed and shared with other
people who are using the welcome
language that they can pull in that data
and use these entities in in combination
with the things that are built in
building a really nice entity store that
has nice labels on all the entities and
properties is not a completely trivial
task just take some time and tweaking
but you can get something in perfectly
usable shape with very little time so
just as an example here the the data set
we're working with for Head Start
locations there isn't a unique
identifier for each of these centers in
the data set so I'm constructing
something that I assume is going to be
unique I'm joining together a grant
number a center name and the zip code
name for each of these things and they
end up looking like they're their unique
values creating an association between
those identifiers z' and all the data
for each of these centers and if you've
got something that looks like this you
know association where the keys are the
the identifier string and then the the
value of that outer association is a
bunch of other key value pairs with
essentially properties and property
values creating an entity type is as
simple as saying entity store name of
the entity type entities goes to this
data set up here and so you register
that as an entity and then you can start
using this just like any other entity
type and language countries or cities or
anything else you get a list of the
entry properties for head start
locations I can create an implicit
entity class lets me look up Head Start
locations where the city of the center
is Cleveland and get a list of those
start generating plots take that list of
centers and do a Geo list plot of them
based on all the coordinates so entity
store could be a whole talk unto itself
to get into all the details of you know
curating and constructing
nice customers in general it's a really
nice way of extending what you've got
you've got a really good data set that
you want to work with staying way you
use built-in Anthony's in the language
anthony store is a great tool I don't
think that I have any other anything
else I need to cover right now I want to
make sure I leave time for questions on
this part of the presentation and Erin
has time to go a little bit deeper into
the process of curating Messier data
sets and more complicated data curation
processes so I can stop there and take
questions are you planning to restore
the full functionality of the financial
data function the question from Tobias a
great question and this one is directly
in my group I we have been gradually
probably slower than some people would
like trying to do that you know we
experienced an issue with our original
data provider for that function
terminating most of most access to that
data we've switched over so that now I
one benefit of the switchover is in
product financial data is using the same
sources as Wolfram Alpha uses for for
answers on the web in the process of
doing that switch over there were some
properties that were lost especially
things related to difference between raw
and adjusted open high low close values
and some other properties most of those
things that many have been restored
there are others that are in in the
process of being restored right now you
know I think if there if there are
particular things that aren't working
the way you expect them to they will
come back I know recently there's an
issue also with volume for many equities
and indices that should be fixed now as
of this week of latest deployment it's
something that we're watching closely
I'm you know it's it's frustrating that
when we when we rely on external data
sources and we have challenges with
those data sources we try to respond as
quickly as you can but sometime you read
too
blowing things to work with a different
provider can take longer than we hope
does Wolfram Alpha rely on curated
datasets to produce outputs is there
risk of retrieving non curated data in
class cleaning this is this is somebody
asking about the essentially this is
about the quality of data in Wolfram
Alpha most of the data in Wolfram Alpha
has gone through some curation process
the level of scrutiny that any data
receives can depend on the domain and
can depend on just how good this the
source data is you know for four domains
like chemistry elements astronomical
data at any of the scientific domains
certainly we're trying to rely on the
most reliable accepted authoritative
sources of data that we possibly can in
domains like people or we know when
we're getting birth dates and birth
places and other sorts of things we try
to find some consensus or a best
possible value in cases but sometimes
there are discrepancies between data
sources and and no single authoritative
source so we had to make some judgment
calls you know there there may be
certain sources we trust more than
others that we will defer to and use
their answer but you know we are we are
also constantly looking at improving
data double-checking data
verifying data points against newer and
better data sets when they become
available and you know trying to make
the data as good as we can another chair
not a question about cryptocurrency use
historical prices for crypto currencies
and financial data this is a really good
question actually this is this is
something we're actively working on
right now I one of the things that has
been a long-standing deficit I think is
not having access to historical currency
conversions of of any type in the
language at least not in a really easily
accessible way we're actively working on
this right now
the
I would expect to see some some
improvements in currency convert and an
inflation-adjusted in your future that
will cover standard currencies as well
as crypto currencies I think I'm gonna
pass this chair over to to Cassidy and
we have a poll another poll question we
want to put out to you now as we
transition to Aaron this question is
about data scraping and this is a topic
that Aaron will be demonstrating and
talking more about in his talk
so as this poll question shows up on
your screen if you would go ahead and
respond and give us a little bit of
feedback this will help but guide our
guide Aaron in his presentation as he
comes up next here
all right hi I'm Erin Enright data
scientist for Wolfram Alpha
and fortunately the most popular data
formats that you seem interested in
scraping come to you relatively well
structured JSON is is a very well
structured and easily imported data
format it comes into Mathematica either
there is a list of rules or sin'
association depending on how you import
it spreadsheets being tabular data or
also come in nicely as has lists of
lists of data what I'm going to be
focusing on today are really the top two
which tend to be treated the same way by
me when I'm scraping HTML and XML HTML
especially tends to be a lot Messier and
a lot more difficult to deal with but I
think the Wolfram language has some
great tools for for dealing with them so
without further ado let's dive into
scraping some HTML we're gonna go from a
website scraping the data out of it and
doing making a data repository object
out of the data that we get from that
website
the website I chose today is the from
the US presidency the American
presidency projects job approval ratings
let's have a quick look at that if we
scroll down a little bit we see a nice
table with a bunch of numbers and dates
and the president's name and so on we've
got a form up at the top where we can
select a president going back to FDR up
to modern times so how to get that data
out there's a easy route
to take first which is using the import
function which will use a lot here today
you feed it the URL as well as the
parameter data and that imports tables
from the other structured data that it
can find in the in the website and
unfortunately in this case the output is
not really optimal it's it's kind of
tough to get down to where you need to
the data that you need we can after
examining it you can find the data that
you that you want but it's really ragged
and messy and tough too
oops tough to deal with here another
option is using full data what full data
does is a kind of a more thorough
automatic scrape of the tables in the
HTML it accounts for empty cells and
cell spans and things like that
once again the data comes out pretty
unwieldy say the lease and it's the data
is ragged we we still have rows of
unequal lengths and it's tough too tough
to deal with a manipulate being a little
bit of a control freak with how I
process the data I don't like to use
data in full data in my imports unless
it's I'm able to get the data out very
quickly and with minimal screwing around
instead what I like to use is importing
in data as an XML object the data that
comes out when you import a website as
XML and XML object looks like so we have
the head of XML object document followed
by a list
followed by a bunch of XML elements and
this gives you a symbolic representation
of the HTML in the webpage if you're
familiar with s expressions and scheme
or racket as they call it these days
it's very much like that where you have
the head XML element the name of the
element a list containing the attributes
for that element and then another list
containing the contents of that element
if we dig through here we start finding
table rows and discover pretty quickly
that the website we're dealing with they
do all their layout through through
tables which if you've you know studied
web design is is kind of it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a no-no and that's why
using data in full data is so unwieldy
so if we examine the source code through
a web browsers a screenshot of using the
inspector in a web browser to examine
the source code here we notice that our
table rows that we want have are all of
the class list date rather the cells
that the table data themselves in the
rows have a class list date we can use
cases to extract those rows and cells
pretty easily and this is how we do that
there we've got our our XML
representation and data and give cases
this pattern of a table row followed by
anything followed by a list of table
data's with the class list state
followed by anything and repeated and we
give it a depth level of infinity in
that start
giving us data that we that looks good
here there's a role for us we have the
start the president's name start date
end date of the poll the colored cell
that we'd see in the in the in the
webpage as well as the approval
disapproval and unsure no data elements
there we can map over those rows there
and extract just the data the data
elements themselves there they are
and if we check the dimensions of that
now we notice that we have some nice non
ragged data we still need to clean up
and structure the data some more now we
need to get the X on their data is not
close to ready to be put into a data set
or an entity store or anything like that
yet we still need to do things like turn
names into entities turn dates and to
date objects turn these numbers into
quantities and so on so if you notice
that in the webpage the president's name
only appears on the first row we see
that up here too there's the first row
and the second row no presence name just
an empty space and so on so we have
we'll have to account for that and we'll
have to account for
things that we don't want such as the
the colors cells here so at this point I
like to get my get an end structure in
mind get get an idea of what I'm working
towards ultimately I want a list of
associations where whoops where I have
the president going to an entity object
a time series of their approval ratings
a time series of their disapproval
ratings and a time series of when
they're your armature or no data and one
of these associations for each president
so here's our first step towards working
toward in working towards that structure
we will take the first element of the
but I'll start over in this will take
the Rose ADA take the rest of it on the
right hand side and for the first part
or run it through the interpreter for
person and there here we have franklin
roosevelt going to a date a date that's
the colored swatch in in the table and
then the numbers here you can see that
we are on our way we don't want the
image element so we will just drop that
it's in position three of every row so
do that and now we're a step closer and
here where you're going to combine a
couple of steps we're going to apply
data object to
the start date of the poll date object
to the end date of the poll ring to turn
if I go into here we can see that these
numbers are strings I could use the
technique that Ellen used of using
interpreter here I'm using an alternate
technique of using 2 expression on the
string to turn it into an integer and
then wrapping that in quantity and
percent and a final little cleanup step
here of taking any place where we have a
string a single string within a list and
just returning that string so let me run
that we get some pretty nice-looking
output to notice that we have these data
object warnings that the dates are
ambiguous basically the Wolfram language
is telling us it doesn't know if that's
the month or if that was the month it
could be month day year or day month
year we can get around that by providing
a date specification where we give the
string that we're interpreting as a date
along with the order of elements in that
string so now the same thing but without
the ambiguity errors
now we have two now our next step is to
make time series out of all of the
approval disapproval and unsure numbers
kinda have a decision to make here in
that time series it needs a single date
I don't believe at this point yet we we
can do a time span on the dates and the
time series so I'm kind of arbitrarily
picking the end date for each poll as
the date point for each time series and
so we will continue building here where
we've got our data I'm sorry we've got
our precedent and then our data is what
we did in the previous step and down
here we have the data structure that we
had in mind at the beginning our final
design where we have the president and
then we take all of the data in with the
approved key and put that into a time
series and same with disapproved and
same with the unsure note data and we
get that nice little output and we're
starting to have data that we can easily
make a date list plot of and so things
are looking good so far
now we need to do this not just for FDR
but for several web pages so we're going
to package up all the steps that we made
here into a single scraping function
it's basically ends up being a bit of a
copy/paste job of the steps that we did
that we did in the in the past it
earlier on in the presentation
where we take our scraper give it a URL
parameter import that URL and within a
module set some um some some variables
in here where we'll have the rows the
data from those rows and then the
results that we're going to return so we
define that function and we'll run that
over a different one of the precedents
picked Nixon here for this and it looks
like it worked so now how we got our
function and now we need to map it over
all of the different presidents if we
examine the URL from the presidency
project you notice that it has after the
question mark there's a bunch of
different parameters and the only
parameter that changes from page to page
is this president the Prez parameter
which is the number of president that
we're talking about it starts with FDR
number 32 and ends with Trump number 45
so we can pretty easily just do a range
of 32 to 45 and math that map a string
drawing over that range which gives us a
list of URLs and then to get our data on
all the presidents we can just map the
scraper that we have over that list of
URLs which takes a moment as it's
hitting several web pages and there we
go it's done so now we have to do
various checks on our data and one of
the things that Alan mentioned was that
interpreter unless you tell
specifically that you want it to return
you can pass to interpreter an ambiguity
function we did not do that we just said
give us your best interpretation of the
input we'll want to check what we have
here with the interpretation of the
president's and you'll notice that
George W Bush appears twice every other
president appears only once if we go
back to the web page when we go to well
the lists of presence will notice the
first president Bush is listed as George
Bush and then the second President Bush
is listed as George W Bush if we go to
the George Bush page we'll see we'll
what we scraped out of there was just
George Bush which interpreter most
likely because George W Bush being the
most recent President Bush picks him by
default we can change we can tweak just
a little bit our presidential approval
scraper function to replace the plane
George Bush with George HW Bush to fix
things there so that we have the right
president and we'll give that a minute
to run in here we see now we have one
instance of every president including
George HW Bush and George W Bush now
let's take our data and turn it into a
data set
there we go and I'm gonna put that into
the Wolfram cloud for safekeeping as
well as for retrieval later on when we
make a resource object out of this data
we'll make a few visualizations of the
data just to explore it a little bit
our first visualization is we will look
at we will grab all of the approval
ratings for the precedents with a in
Plata de as a time series and we'll see
that there each president has a
different color with some repeating
colors and an interesting little plot of
how things have gone as far as approvals
this plot I found a little interesting
the plot of the unsure or no data point
in in the various presidencies well
where I'm I just found it a little fun
that there's a huge peak at the
beginning of every presidency seems
where people are actually taking their
time at least some number of people are
taking their time to judge the president
which is I think reassuring and used
from the from the Wolfram knowledge base
because we have the person entities as
the president we're able to grab their
images and use them in the legend for
the plot to to make things a little more
just a little more fun
how about aggregating the data and
putting it all together so I made a
a path through by joining the paths
through all of the disapproval time
series and making a single time series
out of that and then also a moving
average with a window of four years or
one presidential term just to see how
the disapproval of the presidency moves
over time and the smoothed out version
of it kind of gives a bit of a I think a
bit of a better or more readable plot
but we also have it overlaid on the very
detailed date list plot so now we have
our data set made and we've put it into
the cloud and let's say we want to share
it with others so one thing that you can
do is in Mathematica you can open I'm
sorry a new data resource notebook I
already have one filled out if you open
a new data resource notebook you get
this blank notebook with fields to fill
in and so on I've already gone and
filled one in here for us you give it a
name and title presidential job approval
ratings a description some more details
this data comes from the Gallup poll
it's compiled by your hard peters I'm
the one contributing it to the two here
probably be good to mention Gallup a
source reference citation the URL source
for the data and other metadata is
available here two categories they chose
politics we can also you can choose
multiple categories such as statistics
and so on and the content type this is
all time series data and a few keywords
here's where putting the data in the
cloud is handy are you able to for the
content element initialization section
cloud get that object that we just put
up there and there is our familiar data
set and we fill in this code comes this
is a template that is in the data
resource definition notebook when you
open a new one we're using a data set
data type and once again our cloud
object our default content on element is
that data set and so on so we'll
evaluate those items there and then
would take the examples that we interest
made there are two default examples
retrieving the resource and retrieving
the default content and then the I added
here the examples that we made back in
this notebook where we have the approval
of each individual president's job
performance how many people were unsure
had no data along with photos of the
President and then
packaged up in a module this three step
process here to make this smooth
timeline of of job disapprovals and
there we go now the big step to create
the resource object run this cell which
takes evaluation notebook packages it up
into a resource object that is done and
now we're ready to deploy it you can
deploy it locally on your computer and
and use it yourself
you can deploy privately to your own
cloud account to play publicly to your
own proud cloud account which is what
I'm going to do here would give it a a
title there and cloud deploy it which
will take a moment and then we click on
that link and everything should have now
we have our own you'll notice this is
not in the public data repository but
rather in my own user space on the
Wolfram cloud um and we'll see here's
the the metadata some of the metadata we
have filled in as well as the examples
scroll down this code is copyable so if
someone wants to use your resource
object they can easily just click the
clipboard their copy it to the air
clipboard put it into a Mathematica
window and the notebook and evaluate it
and there we are and there in the source
metadata that we get filled in is down
at the bottom of the page
to submit it to the Wolfram data
repository you could request it
publisher ID and add some information
about their your data resource and then
resource submit the submission process
is just up as simple as you got
valuating that line so there you have in
a nutshell a pretty simple example of of
going from data trapped inside HTML and
making it more computable I am I need to
field questions if we have any here let
me see I think we do have a few flag
here we have one from Persie can you
create a job that gets data from a web
page daily even if the data is not
displayed in table format automatically
the web page you select options on a
form hit download and get a table in CSV
format downloaded the short answer is
yes the long answer is that it really
varies on the web page this is something
that I that that I've dealt with and
it's kind of it depends on the on the
web page and how the the writers of that
web page the authors of that web page
have structured their page and
structured their forms you may want to
look at URL submitting URL execute
functions depends upon if they use get
or post for their form data being
submitted and and so on but it's
absolutely doable if you
it to be something that was run daily
automatically making your scraper a
Wolfram language script and running it
from a cron job or whatever job
scheduler is available in your operating
system is a pretty good option I do have
several reports and things that I run at
work I'm a daily or weekly basis that
are just Wolfram language scripts
triggered by cron and they go and either
scrape something or run a bunch of tests
and then spew output into into a cloud
object that then gets read by Allen or
others in our organization again users
develop their personal or enterprise
data repository separate from the
Wolfram data repository yes and Allen
could probably help me out here a little
bit we can you can deploy first thing
first you can deploy something and have
its permission set to private you can
also create your own permissions group
where where you you give a list of
Wolfram cloud accounts that are able to
access write I mean the only thing that
you really don't get here is there
there's no way to without you manually
constructing it to have some sort of
landing page for your own personal data
repository which contains multiple data
resources and your own personal
resources are not going to be searchable
to other users using research resource
search inside the language but as long
as you have the permission set you can
you can certainly deploy your own
resource objects to your heart's content
and you know share or or publish links
to those whatever way it works for you
those are those are going to be
accessible to anybody else that's going
to you have the permission set correctly
okay let's see is there a way to
asynchronously as opposed to see really
important process wait webpages there
you go
the cryptically named URL fetch
asynchronous function is what you are
looking for their days and look in the
documentation for that and oh you can
see it's been superseded by URL submit
but it's still in the system and will
work for you you are some l submit will
do the h secret is fetching for you
there are also I it might be a good time
to point out there are also uh I I did a
series of twitch screencast where I did
basically especially in the first I did
a series of three twitch screencasts in
the first one I built two resource
objects and the scraping notebooks and
the resource object submission notebooks
are available through the Wolfram
research github account so um those
notebooks are filled out in a little bit
better detail than what I did just here
so we did like state lotteries and
there's the resource subscription let's
just go to the top level and this also
has links to the to the screencasts
themselves if you can't get enough of
hearing me talk about scraping there you
are
well the data science platform take care
of a lot of this data wrangling or data
preparation will remain a manual task
well to some extent I am of the view
that a lot of the data wrangling should
be automated as much as you can
it's it can be very tedious to do it
manually but there's always going to be
some manual component to it you I try to
automate things as much as possible a
huge chunk of my job is we had mentioned
our Alan had mentioned our data curation
team earlier on and how they have to in
particular with you not so much the hard
scientists but our softer areas like
people and and so on where they have to
inspect the data and and verify facts
and stuff and I do as much autumn a huge
chunk of my job is automating as much of
that data collection and verification as
possible but there still has to be a
point where people have to look at where
we have to have human eyes on on the
data and the data sources to look at
them so we're not at that point yet
where it can be fully automated and
there are some areas where especially if
you trust your data source that you're
scraping and and they're pretty
authoritative you can automate a lot of
it but you're not we're not where it's
just going to be push a button and
thoroughly clean data comes out the
other side
yes and last question I see here's a
twitch URL posting UB grades you can see
the those are linked from the screen the
the github page on seeing yep there we
go coming a data curator part two well
back out of that before it starts auto
playing so okay any other questions or
anything I would be glad to answer or
thanks Erin I think we have covered
everybody's questions I think there's a
couple people we promised to follow up
with after the session and that's that's
fine we will do so you'll be getting an
email from from one of us here at
Wolfram if you had a question we
couldn't address right now on the fly
but that does conclude our presentations
today and the the data science webinar
series thank you to Allen and Aaron for
presenting today
we appreciate your participation and I
hope that everyone enjoy the talks and
learned about concepts and tools you can
use to unleash the power of your data we
will send an email to everyone in the
audience with a link to the recording of
this session and which will also have
download links if you missed those
earlier didn't get a chance to download
the notebooks